la musique est sordide affaire de
l'assassinât du petit grégory vient de
connaître son premier dénouement avec
l'inculpation d'un cousin de la ligue
quand il déjà suspecté la semaine
dernière mais cette fois-ci inculpé
d'assassinât car sont malades
son alibi pour le jour et l'heure du
crime c'était l'inculper pour sa part
continue de crier son innocence en tout
cas sur place l'émotion est grande
on le devine aisément le reportage notre
envoyé spécial isabelle b pearson phare
me dit pas plus simplement c'est aussi
le corps vous ni moi ni ma femme aussi
on en a conscience tranquille
c'est ça qui nous a sauvés voilà ce
qu'il disait quatre jours avant
l'ovulation
hier 12h30 quand les gendarmes arriver
là tu rancel bernard laroche est à son
poste de travail
il se prend toujours protégé par la
libye de muriel sa belle soeur de 15 ans
qui a affirmé qu'elle n'avait plus de 15
km
le 16 octobre dernier mais hier matin
nouriel à parler aux gendarmes et aux
juges
elle a avoué qu'elle avait du progrès la
faisait ces boues et c'est finalement
libérer du fardeau qu'elle portait
depuis 20 jours
c'est le témoignage qu'attendaient les
enquêteurs pour pouvoir interpeller
bernard laroche pour de bon car il
savait bien qu'on ne savait pas espéré
avant tout le moulin de jean marc à
l'interrogatoire
jamais il n'avait admis la moindre
jalousie le moindre dépit il n'avait
donné prise à aucune thèse de mobiles
hier à la gendarmerie signale bien
continuer 2010 fera exactement
15h averti par la rumeur publique les
curieux guettait déjà le meurtrier
présumé
sous le préau du palais de justice le
juge lambert lui attendait bernard
laroche signifié son inculpation une
vierge à prendre de l'âge de 9 ans
conservait d'alibi à la roche il avait
accompagné tout le temps du crime
uriel accompagner l et es dans la
voiture c'est sébastien son fils aussi
c'est lui qui sert vraiment quand
vraiment pas vraiment bien c'est est ce
que vivent et ils en voiture dans
l'attenté d'une jauge l'ignorent
totalement et il n'avait pas l'intention
d'inculper muriel non poule pour
l'instant
c'est totalement insu dans la famille on
est consterné jacky vimond qui a été
élevé avec la roche ne comprend pas pour
l'instant plus toujours pas l'expliquer
je pense une explication les gens d'en
haut pour savoir le ch et un monde tout
seul parce que psychologiquement vous ne
savez pas ce qui a pu ce qui a pu
l'amener là cela s'il était tout sourire
et s'ils ont pu devenir fou si c'est
vraiment lui qui a fait le coup c'est
docteur jekyll mr dire que de façade il
est bien mais l'intérieur il est
complètement pourri et son pouvait pas
soupçonner soupçonna ne manque en
personnel en pleurant